when a wheel is rolling without slipping
as we saw before that the contact point
here the contact point is
instantaneously
at rest now if the wheel is rolling on a
surface with friction then it's possible
that we may have a static friction force
but stuck so there could be static
friction may act however static friction
is always depends on the circumstances
now let's just consider two cases
suppose here's a wheel VCM this is a
horizontal surface and in that case the
static friction if the wheel is rolling
with a velocity V in this case F static
is zero and because of that the wheel
will roll without any friction which is
an idealization there's other types of
friction called rolling resistance air
resistance etc which will solve the
wheel down but in a perfect hard wheel
idealized wheel in a vacuum it will keep
on rolling
however if a wheel is going down an
inclined plane and it wants to maintain
the rolling without slipping condition
so here we have vc m and it has some
angular speed we have to be careful
because in this case if we differentiate
ACM is our alpha so what is making the
wheel spin faster it has a non zero
angular acceleration and if we looked at
the forces acting on the wheel then we
have a normal force we have gravity
acting at the center of mass and we also
have static friction and it's precisely
the static friction that is producing a
torque
about the center of mass and that torque
about the center of mass will produce an
angular acceleration so in order for the
wheel to continue rolling without
slipping
it must have both a linear acceleration
which comes from gravitational force
component going down the inclined plane
minus the friction plus the Alpha is
coming from the torque and so this side
if we wrote it as a vector equation the
torque about the center of mass would be
the vector from let's write this as our
cm to where the static friction is
acting so that's the vector R cm
epistatic
cross F static so in this case F static
is non zero so there are many
circumstances in which static friction
can vary between zero value some
possible value and some maximum value
and here we see one more example in
order for the wheel to continue to
accelerate down the inclined plane and
roll without slipping that the static
friction must produce a torque that
causes the angular acceleration and so
we see that static friction depends on
the other constraints in the problem